this is a production of Cornell
University Thank You Chelsea for the
traduction and thank you all for being
here can every hit me okay awesome
um before I get into the science I do
want to highlight and acknowledge all
the undergrads that I've worked with and
had the pleasure to work with in the
last several years from three different
universities University of Florida UC
Riverside and here for now
and then throughout the talk many of
these have contributed to a lot of the
projects I will highlight their names
are their photos and their names in blue
so you can see what work they've
contributed so the rough outline for
today's talk will be at three different
scales the first one would be below the
species level so let see work i've done
with the adaptation of barley
specifically using the composite cross
to which i'll explain in just a few
minutes and then do with some genomic
approaches and some CT scanning
techniques the second part will be at
the species level so be in subtle gilja
in the polymerase ii looking at flower
size across most related species and
then the last part will be map
revolutionary skills so angiosperm wide
questions involving polyploidy and
diversification as well as flower size
and floral fusion so most my work my
interests can be summed up on the slide
I have a big interest in understanding
the genetic component to adaptation some
examples here with such as the Nano
sperry I and the peppered moths happen
below the species level whereas others
such as Darwin's finches and the
cichlids happen at or above the species
level or even higher taxonomic units so
first up is my working barley
this was part of my NSF plant genome
postdoc fellowship with Dan Koenig at UC
Riverside and so let's say we have two
populations of flowers one is like
California it's sunny it's warm it's
very dry these flowers may be kind of
small reddish our second population is
very similar to what it's like outside
today cold rainy not near as warm these
flowers would be bigger yellow so we
have two different populations so you
know what's the genetic component that
drives this well one way we can do that
take individuals from both populations
cross those and do a QTL approach to
look at the genes the loci underlying
the regions that were interested in the
second approach would be to go out in
the field sample many individuals get
genotype data from all those acquired
phenotypes and then do a G wass analysis
to see links between genotype and
phenotype so again we have our two
populations they look to be separate but
they do share an evolutionary history so
at some point back in time they may have
been one population that since diverged
well we also the temperature is like now
so let's say the sunny warm area has a
warmer temperature highlighted in red
the other population is cooler this is
what the temperature is now but going
back in time that may not have always
been the case they could be warmer in
some areas cooler than others so this
makes it really hard to determine what
is going on with adaptation especially a
factory environment now ideally what
we'd like to have would be collections
through time from the different
locations - and at the same time that we
know these changes and temperatures
occur
well conveniently in Riverside we
actually do have a population very
similar to that and that's the composite
cross - of barley so this cross this
population consists of 28 varieties from
around the world that were crossed in
1927 at UC Davis and have been allowed
to grow up grow ever since
usually every every year with one
generation so start of 1927 so that's
our f1 and it goes through F 58 so each
of those great dots is one generation
those blue dots are generations we have
material viable seed that we can plant
in the in the greenhouse or out in the
field and grow up so in close to 100
years those populations been around what
other changes do we see well so if you
look at what was the top end of the line
car around 1927 you see that compared to
what it is today
airline travel flight has changed
drastically than that time as well both
of these things contribute to a change
that plants respond to and that's mean
temperature so you see on the bottom
left here
laughter you're right that overall
temperature has increased since the time
of the formation in fact if you look at
California and look at the 100-year
that's one temperature compared to the
100-year mean you see that early on when
the cc2 was formed California was cooler
than the the mean but then especially in
later years we have it was warmer and so
from the composite crops - we have
sampling along these transitions here
from cooler to warmer so looking at the
CC - a little bit more so again it's 28
parrot lines and they represent the
geographic diversity found in barley so
here we have some other parents
highlighted a few are missing because
those are hybrids and not are not on
this graph and we also have included in
these parents the genetic diversity of
barley so we have samples from Asia from
North Africa from southern Asia and then
we have a genetic distinct genetic
distinct group of two-row barley and so
that two row is also when the major
field it's a big differences in barley
we have six row and two row so we do
include that and we also have samples in
the parents that have black pigmentation
such as on the far corner there and also
ones that are hooded and so we do have a
good representation of barley overall
and so with help from Jessica and imma
we did a common garden greenhouse
experiment where we picked for the
generations so f-18 f28 15 F 58 and we
planted 221 individuals in the
greenhouse as well as the parent lines
we collected DNA to genotype all those
and to acquire phenotypes and we want to
see what is changing anything across
these generations so some of the
phenotypes that we collected we have
some some gross plant for traits such as
height and flowering time there in the
middle we also have the number of spikes
produced as well as a number of tillers
so tillers are response to the
environment the wetter the more
appropriate the environment is the more
tillers there will be and we also
calculated some measures of seed yield
and some characteristics of the way the
seeds looked and so we also genotyped
all these individuals - so barley has a
fairly big genome 5.3 Giga bases
which makes whole genome sequencing a
challenge especially for a lot of
individuals we did sequence the the
parent line so all twenty-eight parents
about a 5x genome sequencing approach
there is a well annotated genome of
barley so we could use that for
resequencing then with the rad seek
because we had a bunch of individuals
almost 1,000 dividuals we did rad seek
or GBS for the progeny as we imputed the
missing data from our whole genome
sequencing data
this approach is virtually well for
barley because it is 95% selfing and we
have big blocks of LD or linkage
disequilibrium so many of the genotype
calls will be the same along the
chromosome so to take all that
phenotypic data that we collected and
you look on how how it changes over time
so here's a PCA plot with all the data
include the gross morphology of the
spike in the seed data the orange dots
are the early generation and the purple
dots are the the late generation so what
you see is that in this trait space as
it goes from early to late the variation
diminishes so the closer to points are
on this graph the more similar they are
so you see that the orange spans most of
that most of that plot and the purple is
on the bottom corner there and so we are
seeing big scale changes across
generation well we want to see if
selection may be acting on those
phenotypes so before I go to the data
just a quick review of this of the three
types of selection we may see so we may
see a stabilizing selection where the
two extremes are the two tails are
removed and things are more to the
central optimum value we may see
directional selection or that optimum
value is pushed in one direction or
another or because he disruptive
selection where the opt the the tails
are increased in the optimum value is
decreased and with CC 2 it was grown in
large population sizes at Davis around
5,000 dividuals for each generation so
we don't expect kinetic drift to be a
likely factor in how this population is
evolving so if you look at one given
trait so this case flowering time again
we have the orange B in the early
generations and the purple being late
generations what we see is a 7-day shift
in flowering time later seven day shift
and flowering
from early to late so the early
generation flowered on median value is
59 days whereas the later generations
we're at 66 days and we do see that
those tails especially the early tails
are being removed in the greenhouse
setting so we look at the genotypes now
the null hypothesis we expect or one
would be that all parent lines will
contribute equally to the progeny so we
should have equal representation of
every genotype that's not what we see so
when we do pairwise comparisons so along
these these 5 triangle plots from
founders f-18 f28 and f-15s 58 each line
here would represent one individual on
both sides doing pairwise comparisons
the darker the line the higher the
genetic difference is the the more gold
align the more similar they are so we
see is the founders are genetically very
different from each other which makes
sense based on the the geographic and
genetic sampling we have with an as you
go from f-18 to F 58
things become more and more similar and
that there's only a few areas that
really stand out so we wanted to look at
this a little bit more and so we can do
that by looking at inheritance by
descent so here's one example let's say
we have two individuals they blue
chromosome and a red chromosome after
you're several generations are crossing
we don't always inherit big blocks
together on the chromosome however we
can look at certain pairs or certain
parts of that chromosome and say these
are inherited by descent so on the
bottom here you see those blue portion
of the chromosome between the individual
one individual two that are shared
similar with the red part in n two and
three so if we do this with barley what
we see is that two of the two of the
genotypes to the parents Atlas and
Maison carrée actually make up 70% of
all the genotypes that we see in late
generations the other northwest Africa
lines also make up a big portion of that
and then all the other lines the other
20 so lines are making a very small
portion and so on this clustering
diagram - you see that Atlas and Maison
career are both very closer to
genetically related to each other so at
is playing a big role in this population
and so that may not be too surprising
that the Spanish monks your atlas in
California about a hundred years before
this before the inception of cc2 so it
was well adapted well as suited to the
California climate and so one hypothesis
is that is locally adapted on a fine
skills what we see in California but we
also won't look at do we see genetic and
it's a bit changes associated with these
other Mediterranean land races so
there's other land races from northwest
Africa
so compare combining the phenotypic data
we have with the genetic data we can do
G wasps on each of the traits and such
as flowering time here we see two
significant hits so anything above that
red line is a significant hit so we find
two genes BR in h2 and BR and h3 that
are contributing to flowering time and
these both are known to interact with
photo period and vernalization now one
of the vrh to gene is not found in many
of the spring varieties was found in the
or not found in the winter of rice we
found the spring varieties so we know
that it's coming from somebody's will
adapted genotypes and we can look at see
how allele frequencies changed through
the generations and so the one
additional thing we're doing with Dan
[ __ ] Wood and Liz munch at Michigan
State University is looking at CT
scanning of the spike so we grew up 290
not 290 accessions from this population
and and replicate so in duplicate and we
CT scanned all of those to look at
topological analysis to pair with
genetic data so we can scan four or five
six spikes all at one time and then
threshold bills out individually then
take that 3d plot and turn it into a
more two-dimensional plot on the bottom
left there to do to get measurements
from length with an area some of these
traits so I was hoping to really have
some data for this but it's been a
little bit slower of analyzing this I'm
hoping to actually have stuff to share
at the body meeting in July so if any of
you go in there you should see more of
that then but what we do expect to see
though is the reduction in the variance
of morphologic or the spike morphology
over time
similar what we see with some of those
other traits and the genetic component
of that so with the CC - a quick wrap-up
of that so we can see evolution
happening on a small time scale so this
is less than 50 generations we're
looking at and this is also after that
initial shock period of when they cross
these geographically genetically and
phenotypically different accessions
together our diverse accessions together
we find that the genetic diversity
decreases in later generations and is
centering on two genotypes that are well
adapted to California and we also see
stabilizing selection appears to be
acting on many of the traits if you look
at those individually so this is just
462 so it's not a big representation of
all of barley however we have a
diversity panel that we put together in
the lab that represents 435 lines from
around the world so here's some example
and so each of those are plotted on the
world map there and they represent the
climatic variation found on all USDA
lines and so you can compare our panel
here in the bottom right and the mean
annual temperature to all the USD lions
all 13 thousand USD lines we do cover
most of that we don't cover the extreme
tells but recovered most of variation
observe there and so we're interested in
how this black morphology will change
changes associate with somatic gradients
and the Centers of domestication
specifically what we're looking at is do
we see clustering of spike morphology
associated with the proposed
domestication of this and barley which
there are two really well understood
events potentially more both happying
around the Fertile Crescent area and we
also want to see do we see notable
trends in spike morphology along a
latitude or longitude or climatic
gradients and so some work has been done
on barley showing that there are
climatic groupings or groupings genetic
groupings of barley across different
area so we have Africa Europe Asia but
none of these have looked at the
phenotypes to go with it so we're
interested is there sniffs associated
with given spike morphologies
that suggests adaptive significance on a
broad scale and barley
so all this work with the genotyping and
phenotype you know barley sit put me up
really well for when I came here to
Cornell in Chelsey's lab so working with
Erika Steiger and Susan Micucci I've
been involved in the Samak and rice
project so this the samake Maroons are
culturally independent people of the
upper suriname river and so serene am
here is in South America and the
suriname river is this river that goes
right down the middle of the country
from the major lake there and so this
group they practiced traditional rice
cultivation and uniquely for them
compared to other areas they're
increasing the number of varieties that
they are growing instead of decreasing
so they're not becoming a more a
monoculture they're actually increasing
how many lines they're growing so for my
involvement I'm interested in two main
goals one is to describe the genetic
diversity of cultivated rice and
determine if the named varieties are
true genetic units is they don't really
know that down there and the try
determine where does the rice come from
is it of Asian descent so arises a
sativa or is it African rice the Arizer
glabra rima and all this work has been
funded by the Atkinson sensored and so
Rosie and Erica went to the field last
summer they helped in the the harvesting
and they documented the diversity of
rice they found they collected a bunch
of panicles as well and then Rosie's put
together a nice poster here the
highlights at least the seed diversity
that we see in the samake rice that is
grown and so it's all this data they
brought back from the field with again
Rosie's help and with help of Dan
Nichols we are looking at measuring
traits from the panicles and from the
seeds and seeing how these are Coulee
together so if you look at correlation
analysis we see three groupings of
traits you see one with the the the
grouse plant trait so flowering time
size of the plants we see another
grouping here in the middle with the
panicles and then our third grouping
with C traits so you think all this data
together and perform a principal
component analysis
and you color thanks bye village we were
hoping to see that there be distinct
groups in the different villages well
that's not the case some some villages
have more diversity of what they are
growing it seems like but based on the
traits that we have from the field we
don't have enough information to do that
but we're hoping to uh spare this data
this morphological data with genetic
data so the help of many undergrads
right now we are growing about 450 lines
in the greenhouse and will we be
harvesting leaf material very soon to do
shallow skim seek on each of these
samples so between 0.5 and 1x sequencing
on everything and then we will compare
the resequencing data we get back to the
diversity database that the Mapuche lab
has an acute missing genotypes that way
so this should help us allow us to
answer those questions of what is the
genetic unit and the Samak in rice and
where does it come from so shifting
gears just a little bit now we're gonna
go back a little bit above the species
level so this is work I did with Pam and
Doug Psaltis the University of Florida
working on a small genus South to Juliet
and the palm on EAC so early on my PhD
career I spent six weeks at Cambridge
University in the lab of beverly glover
and this was a book that she had out
that I remember reading there my
master's program and early on my PhD we
sat down one day and talked and I told
her I was interested in flower size she
asked me do you know how much is known
about that
I said no she pulled the book it said
two paragraphs so this whole book I
related to flower size so it's mostly a
black box I sew him back to Florida
after the trip and I told Doug Psaltis
this and so the question I had to ask
was do I stick with the question that
may be easier so not this one but other
potential PhD questions or as Doug
should tell me swing for the fences so
of course I picked the more difficult
route and went for flower size so if you
look at it flower size across the
angiosperms we have the smallest flowers
in wolfie a-- which are microscopic and
then the largest flowers and rafflesia
which there were 3 feet wide in the
polymerization themselves we see a very
wide range of sizes as well
three millimeters on the far left to
seven centimeters here on the right this
again this is all in Palma da sea
so a quick graphical representation of
that let's say that three millimeters is
this little blue dot here then the
biggest flower and that family would be
this so a substantial difference quite
drastic difference this would be length
so not diameter links that's the length
of the Corolla length of the flower and
so a flower size can be driven in part
by by pollinators or Ponies and
syndromes so if you have if you're a
hummingbird pollinated or hawk moth
pollinated these will tend to be larger
longer flowers be pollinated flowers
tend to be shorter more open more bowl
shaped butterfly flowers they'll be
smaller very narrow than if you're
selfing if you don't require a
pollinator those are often very small
flowers such as a rabbit opposites which
is mostly selfing as well and so this
could be one of the major adaptive
reasons for different flower sizes so in
the Paul Mooney AC there's about 462
species the center of distribution is in
Western North America
mailee California and they're found in
the deserts and the mountains out there
but many are also popular ornamental
plants especially any of the Fox species
this group also has a rich history of
pollination biology starting with the
grant and grants work in 1965 or they
looked at a lot of these things in the
field and there's several labs currently
working on pollination biology aspects
in this group so there wasn't a great
phylogeny to begin with implemented AC
so we expand the phylogeny to about 80%
of the species sampling and this shows
some of the diversity we see across the
phylogeny and the support values of
these nodes so a lot of the deeper nodes
are well supported from maximum
likelihood analyses and bootstrap what
would you get some more than more of the
tips become less less clear and then the
group that I became interested in for
this next part
souther gilja so it's a very small group
four or five species clustered here so
within this group here's the examples of
the flowers they range from two and a
half centimeters to eight millimeters so
not as not as drastic as
the whole family but still quite a bit
of variation there and so the goals of
this project were to integrate follow
genetic phenotypic and developmental
analyses of floral traits so we
reconstruct a phylogeny using both
Placid and nuclear markers to get really
clear what the relationships were
between species characterize the
cellular differences and how those
relates to flower size overall and then
look at the genetic underpinnings of
this so with the help of margarita
Hernandez we designed targeted gene
capture probes for a hundred nuclear low
side and that should work in this family
using the 1kp dataset transcriptome as
we design the probes from two species of
flocks which are closely related to such
a gilja we have one species or one
sample from the sister family and then
another example in the order era
Kaylee's so when we're designing these
probes we built probes for low sigh that
looked like this top one where you have
short introns and fairly long exons for
the probes to sit so we can pull those
out some of those that we did not use
such as these bottom ones where you had
very long introns and very short exons
so those are not ideal or capture and
sequencing so when we captured this data
and sequence it here's an example of one
of the plots that we get so this is sort
of a larger study including these but
what we see is that we have 61 nuclear
genes that have a that have recovered a
big portion of the protein links so on
these graphs along the x-axis is each
gene along the y-axis is each sample the
darker that box the more of the full
length protein sequence it recovered so
I see from nuclear markers we have some
areas that did not do very well but most
limited fairly fairly well if you look
at the plastid markers which were not
involved in the probe set but we still
sequence as a byproduct we get nearly
complete coding regions for all 480
genes in that group so using
concatenation and coalescence methods we
built the tree and with the support
values so here's one tree from the racks
a mouse to the concatenated nuclear data
sets
and what we see is that Satsuki Lia are
monophyletic and we have plotted next to
each species the the picture of the
flower and also what this pollinator is
and so some of the out-group species
that we have in gilja most lonar selfing
very small the first two diverging
species in south to gilja Australis and
the timur i are also very small and
selfing and then we have this cluster of
species here and the something gilja
splendens and kara folia that are out
crossing mo out crossing and much bigger
compare the other members in this group
and so I was interested in what is the
major contributor to flower size
differences in these species is it the
number of cells or is it cell size now
looking at the literature I could be
either one so an aqua Li Jie the nectar
Spurs they found that it was cell size
was driving those differences in petunia
it was the number of cells but then if
you look at the the differences in
styling and criminal it was both cell
size and cell number so this point we
set it up where we could have when we
find anything unless we didn't know well
the first part was to say how are we
going to quantify cell shape so to do
this we took flowers from all attacks
that we were interested in collected the
four stages so we have a 10 thesis or
which is the mature stage and then we'd
also collect that 25% the the length and
thisis 50% at length and thesis and 75%
link that in thesis and thesis we do
this for 4 plants from each taxa and we
fixed the flowers and glutaraldehyde we
then stained those with aniline blue and
image those under a confocal microscope
now we have to do a confocal because the
first of the help of mildo we started
doing SEM and so we have two parts of
the flower here we have the petal low
which has the conical cells those are
very clear you can tell where one one
cell is and where the next cell however
in the curl to here it's very unclear
about where one cell starts no time
stops as so SEM was not a good approach
however compared the comfortable with
the staining mantling blue now we are
getting the outlines of the cells and we
can very clearly see what the cell walls
are and
measure those and so we're able to
measure cells across the entire flower
through different stages of developments
one last thing to show you before we
start looking at the data for this part
is to figure out where we were in the
flower we use a value of compactness to
help us determine what the cells look
like in that area so let's say we have a
cell or we have a perfect circle with
the perimeter of 10 so the perfect
circle has a compactness value of 1
keeping the perimeter the same but
changing the proportions of that can
drop your compactness value down so a
square would be around 0.78 a small
rectangle 0.75 and then as has become
much much more elongated that value
drops down even further so this helps us
determine how to classify the different
cells in the flower so using this value
we found four types of cells in most
flowers we have the conical cells which
have a compactness value of around 0.8
to 0.95 so not pure circles but very
circular we see transition cells that
are starting to become somewhat
elongated but not really then we see
jigsaw cells which have the lowest
compactness value these fit together
really well and then we have more
straw-like cells the elongated cells
that are also very low compactness value
now each of these cell types have a
particular place on the flower so the
petal lobes are going to are here they
have the conical cells that lobe to
margin as where the transition cells are
the upper part of the petal tube is the
jigsaw cells in the lower part is
elongated cells and so going through
development we can see how big these
cells are and how much they're and and
what role they're playing so as the
flower goes from small to half to mid to
full you can see that early on the cells
are all very similar and an overall area
then as the flower starts to expand the
elongate the trans the elongation
elongated cells start going first and
then you start really getting clear
separation later in development from the
conical of the transition the jigsaw and
the elongated cells
you compare the sizes between the
different species what we see is that we
see distinct groupings but of the jigsaw
cells and the elongated cells based on
the size of the flower so for the jigsaw
cells first these are the ones on the
upper part of the Corolla - all the sets
of Gilley's species are have the boxes
around red so you see a group with
larger cells and those are going to be
the the biggest species the biggest
flowered species in this group and we
see a group that has the smaller cells
and these are going to be mostly those
selfing species the outer group of gilja
even though those flowers are smaller
the size of the cells change so it looks
like those two general are not behaving
the same way when it comes to the
relationship between cell size and
flower size you look at long gated cells
we see a little a similar pattern we see
the biggest biggest flowers have larger
cells and the smaller flower or smallest
farmers case has a different size class
so we can see that the size also the
size has an impact on how big the flower
is but also the proportion of the flower
that each cell contributes has a role so
as the flower is developing the
proportion of conical cells go down and
the proportion of elongated cells that
make up the flower are increasing and
then we see these transits are these
jigsaw cells only at the mature stages
we don't see those at any other stage
through developments we think that this
has a big role in the really long
flowers to help support that flower as
it's hanging out there because the the
structure is stronger with the inner
leaf cells than their cells are just
side by side so the comparison of this
so we see significant differences in
cell size between the different taxa for
jigsaw cells then elongated cells the
larger mature flowers have a larger
proportion of these jigsaw cells in the
smaller cell then the smaller flowers do
if you estimate the number of cells
based on these measurements and what
part of the flower looking at the two
biggest facts that we had had more cells
and several hundred more cells
everything else but all the other ones
were very similar numbers so we think
that cell number
isn't having as big impact as the size
of the cell so morphologically we see a
difference but other changes genetically
so using the transcriptomic approach we
sequence all the same individuals at the
same stage we pulled the reeds together
by developing stages to look for
differentially expressed genes if we can
see that between a 1/2 stage in the mid
comparison we see 0 transcripts
differentially expressed between the mid
and mature 45 genes or transcripts and
between the half and the mature we see
784 transcripts being a difference in
expression we do have some genes of
interest based on a hypothesized
organ size pathway I'll show next and
four of these genes two of these are
involved in cell wall formation and
upkeep one is with growth factors and
the other one is a sucrose producing
flower flower gene so looking at this
pathway in order to get larger organs
for the organ growth we need to have so
elongation and so that could be as
involved with those cell wall genes
because the cell won't need to be
modified to grow a growth factor growth
protein factors and also a sucrose
producing so those four cannons fit in
this pathway here if you look at the
expression from the transcriptome data
so each species is one box and from left
to right is it goes up in development so
we have half mid and full so what you
see in both these cell wall genes we can
see a higher expression in the mature
flowers than we do anywhere else in
development this coincides really nicely
though with that change in cell shape
that we see where from the from the
midst mature we see the change from
elongated cells the jigsaw cells so we
have emphasized that these genes are
involved in reforming that cell wall to
allow it to change shape in to expand
those same pathway the organ pathway
also has other hand is in volved that's
been identified in a rapid OPS's that is
involved in organ size some of these are
cell division inhibitors such as Big
Brother there's a so elongation
inhibitor with big petal and then so you
long Gatien genes gatha and long fo Lea
and so we can compare
though these four show differential gene
expression as well and if we compare
their expression profiles we see that
again for all these species those genes
both the enhancer in the hibbott er are
both up regulated early in development
now how can that be
well if you compare that how the
different cells the cells are changing
in size one potential way is that maybe
these genes are being expressed in
different parts of the flower so we just
say cold flower transcript our mRNA for
transcript columns we couldn't separate
it out but it is quite possible that say
maybe one of these inhibitors is
inhibiting those those jigsaw cells from
forming early on but the other one is
enhancing the transition cells and the
conical cells to grow early on and so
from all the transcriptome work so we
see many uni genes or genes that are
associated with cell wall changes auxin
and dribbling pathways across the
different taxa we see for these genes
that fit into the organ size pathway and
different parts as well as some that are
candidate genes for that same pathway
however we do need to have future work
to see what the what these genes are
functionally doing it's not the gilja so
that's been a long-term goal of mine so
for the last few minutes I want to
transition to the macroevolutionary
project so doing above the species level
and there's three parts of this so the
first part is with Pam and Doug Psaltis
at Florida we're looking at polyploidy
work here with Chelsey of the fusion and
then work with Jim Coan
a former grad student here at Cornell
who's now at Kettering University
looking at flower size so start off the
polyploidy
so polyploidy your whole genome
duplication was initially thought to be
an evolutionary dead end so that's from
Stebbins 1950 and so this is when you
doubled the chromosomes or more case so
the diploid you have two pairs of each
chromosome and the example here now you
have three pairs for each chromosome and
so more recent of views on polyploidy is
that having this extra DNA content may
help to survive or in some cases even
thrive and disturb environments if
you're if you're facing climate change
against herbivores another consequence
of this genome doubling is also in some
cases the size of the fruit it can be
produced so up here the bigger one is
the polyploid of the strawberry and the
small one is a diploid and so if whole
genome doubling is adaptive there's been
some other studies that show that
there's a appears to be a lag phase
before changes in diversification occur
and so but it's unclear if how long this
lag phase is and should you determine it
by the number of nodes on a tree or
absolute time based on divergence time
estimation from that same tree so using
an angiosperm phylogeny of almost 32,000
tips we were able to place a 106 paleo
polyploid events from 1kp data onto this
tree and we're interested in what's the
relationship between the doubling events
and changing the diversification and can
we quantify this lag phase and do we see
this so before I get to the results of
this I want to walk through a few of the
examples so some MOC examples of what we
did so the first wasn't a character
independent diversification analysis so
we have a small tree here each tip
represents a genus and variate genus we
know how many number of species are
involved are found in that genus so for
the character independent
diversification we can run through and
say based on the topology and number of
species where we can find shifts in
diversification so in this case the red
would be upshifts or increase in the
diversification the blue be down shifts
or decreases another analysis we did was
character dependent so the same tree
same number species but now we see
traits and we want to see are those
traits involved in diversification so we
have three different states of traits we
have the black triangles the blue
diamonds and the purple half moon so
these analyses we can see are their
shifts in diversification associate
these traits so in this case we would
see an upshift and diversification for
the blue diamonds and a downshift in the
black triangles the last two analysis we
did was a sister clade species richness
comparison where we compare the number
of species for an event so let's say we
have a polypoid event here we want to
take all the descendants of that event
species so that of that compared to the
sister clade so for the first one we see
it's a comparison of 850 species
compared to 10 for that second event
there it'd be a 1010 versus 2 so I mean
kind of the number of species present
downstream of these events and then the
final analysis was a looking at lag time
before diversification so here we have
one event and we see a almost
instantaneous shift in the versification
following that whereas some events here
such as this one right here may take two
or three nodes before we see changes and
so looking at the the character
dependent diversification and certain
clades so the monocots the stairs and
the roses we can see just polyploidy
effect diversification so we limited the
model that you had to be subsequent
event so you had 0 would be no polyploid
events 1 would be 1 you can go directly
the 2 or you go back to 1 but you can't
go from 1 to 4
so have you sub subsequent and serial
these musi plots showing the posterior
distribution of each of the rounds of
polyploidy show that so when you have
one round steps in the rosettes
which is the gray has a lower
diversification rate net diverse
generation then when you have two rounds
of polyploidy
which are both lower than if you have
three rounds and we notice between the
three major groups the mana cost of
stairs and roses they don't behave the
same way so it looks like that increased
rounds of polyploidy you often but not
always lead to higher diversification up
to a certain point if you have too many
rounds of diversification it looks like
that actually may be hurting your case
such as when you have four rounds here
in the roses that diversification rate
goes down and it also looks like the
major lineages are not behaving the same
way and so if you look at the whole tree
again are actually part of the tree for
the other types of analysis we did so we
see that 61 of the 160 events show a
diversification within four nodes so a
lag time of the four nodes are around 22
million years based on this tree and
that 70 of these events show increases
in species richness but not necessarily
changes in diversity
and compare their sister plate so this
project really got me interested in
angiosperm wide questions so taking the
the the set up for this when working
with Jim Coan we now are looking at
those same genes that I showed earlier
for flour size on a bigger scale so most
these have been identified in
characterizing rapid OPS's but not
really any other non model system so I
was looking at these on Paul Mooney AC
and he was looking at raj and AC for
these same genes but we had a question
of is there a bigger pattern here that
we're not seeing
so using that one the one KP data we've
constructed a small data set of 118
flour 400 transcriptomes from a hundred
teen species plus we had four additional
transcriptomes that we had built and
looked at 32 genes 32 these candidate
genes across the angiosperms we also
built a tree for the background
comparison of 230 putative copy genes to
compare with selection analysis we are
doing so we we for each of these genes
we did translated alignments we did
Pamela nalle' sees to look at synonymous
with nonsynonymous substitutions and the
presence of absence of these genes this
phylogeny here in the bottom right is
our 122 species tree with flower size
mapped on there so you can see that some
of these parts of the tree we see
flowers are much better than others so
using this tree to look at presence or
absence of genes we see the big scale
differences so two of the candidate
genes one is ghast one we can look at
the presence or absence across the major
orders of angiosperms so in this case
the glue is absence and the oranges
presence so for gas one we see that most
of the things in lamby Haley's are
missing this gene or it's not expressing
the transcriptomes that we have whereas
in fig leaves that gene is being
expressed if you looked at dar seven
another gene the patterns flipped where
that gene is absent or we can't find it
in fig alleys what is there in Lamy
Ailey's and so we started doing this we
realize we need to have a bigger data
set to be to have more robust
conclusions so the help of David work
here at Cornell we are building a much
bigger data set and he's interested in
looking the floral fusion genes across
the angiosperms so for the flowers we
have some flowers that are fused the
petals are fused together and some that
are not and we know that there's at
least five genes that we're targeting
initially to look at these and see what
their role may be so jagged rabbit ears
cup shaped cotyledon and as1 we're
looking at the patterns of expression of
these genes and then doing the pamela
nalle' c so look at selection and if we
can't find the genes in our
transcriptomes we're going to start you
were going to utilize the sequence
genomes of close to eight species to see
if that gene is actually there and we're
just missing it in the transcriptome so
we increase our sampling here so this is
an overview of the angiosperm Tree of
Life and the number of flower
transcriptomes we have the number of
species we have across that tree the the
boxes are the blue boxes around some of
the the families and orders are things
that we're missing but we do represent
now 168 species in the angiosperms and
most of the major orders of angiosperms
with multiple accessions species
available when possible so we have this
big data set David and I have gone
through assembled the transcriptomes for
all 168 species now we're setting up an
automated blast pipeline to search and
filter out the genes of interest in his
case the five fusion genes we're going
through align things with math build
gene trees figure out which genes are
present absence in our data sets and
then translate those to open reading
frames for downstream analysis of
substitution sonometers nonsynonymous
substitutions so the take-home message
from all this point from the whole talk
is that we see rapid adaptation and
extensive changes in barley phenotype in
barley in less than 40 generations
flower size is an important factor in
pollination success and it looks like
cell size is a big factor in the
differences in flower size between close
related species different orders of
angiosperms appear to have different
patterns of expression and organ size
genes we're still trying to uncover that
and see what that pattern really is
we're also seeing that polyploidy can
likely be a contributor
the adaptive significance and that we
see higher species numbers in a lag
phase prior to diversification in the
angiosperms so this is a lot of the
research so I've also done some stuff
outside the research lab and one thing I
did was giving kind of a lab experience
to high school students to teach them
over the summer so we created two
different modules that included hands-on
DNA extractions from leaf material
collected in the field
Jil electrophoresis and PCR the first
one was a plant pollinator interactions
and a phylogenetic slab over two summers
in Florida we we had 247 participating
high school students as well as 10 high
school teachers some of these have
actually used this in their classroom
since and then one summer we had a
forensic case which again had 48 high
school students and they all really
enjoy this opportunity and they did the
same techniques that we do in the
research lab extracting DNA running
their gels and so forth they all seem to
really enjoy that
and currently I'm still involved with
some outreach opportunities the big one
playing role right now is letters to a
pre scientist so I get in pal letters
from a middle school student once every
three or four months an actual
handwritten letter which is pretty cool
to get mail when I was in California I
participated in the girls build la stem
career fair and since being here at
Cornell I've also participate in the the
Botanical Gardens Judy's Day the Family
Learning Festival they had going on
there so to wrap up I highlight a lot of
people that help this project there's
many many more that we're not included I
do appreciate all the help and then a
lot of my funding from my PhD and from
my dissertation or registration a my
postdoc now with NSF and if I have any
time for questions I'll be happy to
answer those thank you
[Applause]
works for all since there's transit
there accident both so I haven't done
this much yet so I'm at the defer to
Chelsea on that one I don't know
so I don't know so this is for all the
angiosperms yeah we haven't talked about
that yet so the first part we're doing
right now is the sinus search to see if
these genes that are involved in fusion
are found in the floral transcriptomes
we didn't we then need to relate that
back to what's being done as their
fusion versus not so what we're doing
with the flower sighs we haven't talked
about that yet yeah for an hour fishing
hopefully we'll catch something big and
then see where we go from there I don't
know yet yes so when they so that's a
good question so with the barley
adaptation was every seed that was
putting on the ground collected and
harvested at the end so the folks at UC
Davis try to minimize the amount of
artificial selection that they had so
from what my understanding is was that
they put everything out in the field
they harvested everything that was done
in the growing season and then some of
the stocks were saved for future work
and the rest were put back out so they
tried to minimize that but we weren't
there when it was happening so we're so
most of the the changes we've seen maybe
see we hope or do to just natural
selection and not any artificial
selection but we were not there when
that project was ongoing yes kind of on
a related piece with that part of the
population once you get past you know
have six f7f base i'm like that you've
effectively fixed homozygosity in the
population so then you're really doing
selection on pole individuals
as opposed to on the whole team right so
you're just changing the frequency of
individuals in population my question is
how do you how do you separate
adaptation of the whole genome from
adaptation you've just a couple of few
genes in those individuals that were
being safe yeah no that's a very good
question so with the data weird where we
have now because we have the Razzie data
for the snip calls for most of that and
so we are trying to to differentiate
that so we know that so the reference
genome of barley the more X line is
lacking some of the genes that we are
finding that show to have a response
like the flowering time genes they don't
have all those and so we're trying to
disentangle that it's a it's not easy
and so we're working on finishing that
part up I will say though one thing I
did not mention so all the cc2 work was
done in davis but a generation 24 they
took some of those samples and moved it
from davis to bose in montana and what
we see so and the davis lines we see a
drastic menacing of genetic difference
morphological difference but in the
bosun line we actually see the
difference we see a different story
where some of the really rare genotypes
that were rare in Davis are now more
prolific so in Davis by f-18 it's all
six-row barley but if you go to f50 in
Bozeman two-row barley makes about 50%
of population again so we are seeing
swing so I don't know how to which we're
trying to answer all those questions yes
so why is the hypothesis for changes and
responsive polyploidy in those groups to
be honest I'm not sure at this moment I
might be the number of species and
win-win along the history at this point
so yeah so with that KP boundaries so
there's been several studies and we
could move a little bit to it this one
that shows that the events that happened
around that KP boundary or right after
that whether there may be more disturbed
or open open niche space those seem to
have a bigger change in diversification
following those and other ones the one
drawback makes it harder to analyze this
because we're the ones we're doing we're
just too paleo events we're not really
looking at recent events and so that's
also difficulty in the literature where
you have some that are happening let me
less than six million years ago and so
they say that that's the lag phase that
you need however it may be it's longer
but they just haven't hit that yet and
so yeah that's something I want to look
into more and so expand it out we think
that instead of the hundred sixty place
we could potentially place up to about
250 so be very interesting to use a
bigger tree sometimes in published last
couple years and a more dense sampling
and so you do we see listing pattern and
can be a pinpoint like where it's
happening on that tree better so a
quarter of the population of Salina
might die LCP Susan's population the
religions these are similar to japonica
mechanisms yes it was a certain having a
sumac and rice I I don't think it's been
worked on it all before and so part of
the grant with the Atkinson foundation
or Atkinson Center was to actually look
at that and so the reason this
particular group is interest so the
their cultural history their folklore is
that when they escaped from the
plantations on the coast they hid the
rice seeds in their hair and then moved
to the center of the country and so
therefore klore says that their rice is
probably African descent and so we want
to see really can we see what the role
of the Asian versus the African rice and
there's part in certain parts of the the
chrome
parts of the genome that are being
selected for that for the overall
broader look at CERN ham in general no I
don't know what's gonna happen there
kind of see what the Samak and rice
looks like first and see what we can do
and then expand out if we can this has
been a production of Cornell University
on the web at cornell edu